Puis nous avons le moi conscient.
L'expérience spécifique d'être vous ou d'être moi.
Le personnage principal dans ce film intérieur
est l'aspect de la conscience auquel nous nous accrochons le plus.
Commençons avec les expériences du monde
et avec l'idée importante du cerveau en tant qu'engin de prédiction.
Imaginez être un cerveau.
Vous êtes enfermés dans un crâne,
à tenter de comprendre ce qui se passe dehors.
Il n'y a ni son ni lumière à l'intérieur du crâne.
Tout ce dont vous disposez sont des impulsions électriques
qui ne sont qu'indirectement reliées aux choses de ce monde,
quelles qu'elles soient.
La perception — déchiffrer ce qui est là —
relève sûrement d'un processus de conjecture éclairée
où le cerveau combine ces signaux sensoriels
avec ses attentes ou croyances antérieures sur l'ordre du monde
afin de former la meilleure hypothèse sur la cause de ces signaux.
Le cerveau n'entend pas de son et ne voit pas de lumière.
Notre perception est sa meilleure hypothèse
sur ce qui se passe dans le monde.
Laissez-moi vous donner quelques exemples.
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu cette illusion
mais j'aimerais que vous y pensiez différemment.
Si vous regardez ces deux carrés, A et B,
ils devraient vous apparaître dans deux nuances de gris différentes.
Mais ils sont en fait exactement de la même couleur.
Je peux l'illustrer.
Si je place une deuxième version de l'image ici
et que je relie les deux carrés avec une barre de gris,
il n'y a aucune différence.
C'est la même nuance de gris.
Si vous ne me croyez toujours pas,
je vais amener la barre de l'autre côté.
C'est un seul bloc de gris, il n'y a aucune différence.
Ce n'est pas un tour de magie.
C'est la même nuance de gris,
mais enlevez cette barre et les couleurs sont différentes.
Ce qui se passe ici,
c'est que le cerveau utilise ses attentes initiales
profondément intégrées dans les circuits du cortex visuel
qu'une ombre portée obscurcit l'apparence d'une surface,
de sorte que nous voyons B plus clair qu'il ne l'est vraiment.
Voici un autre exemple
montrant la rapidité du cerveau à utiliser de nouvelles prédictions
pour changer nos expériences conscientes.
Écoutez ceci.
(Voix déformée)
C'est étrange, non ?
Écoutez encore et essayez de comprendre quelque chose.
(Voix déformée)
Toujours étrange.
Écoutez ça à présent.
(Enregistrement) Anil Seth : Le Brexit est une très mauvaise idée.
(Rires)
Je le pense.
Vous avez entendu quelques mots, non ?
Écoutez le premier extrait. Je vais vous le passer à nouveau.
(Voix déformée)
Ouais ? Vous pouvez maintenant entendre des mots.
Encore une fois, au cas où.
(Voix déformée)
Bon, qu'est-ce qui se passe ici ?
Ce qui est remarquable, c'est que l'information sensorielle
qui entre dans le cerveau n'a pas changé du tout.
C'est la meilleure hypothèse de votre cerveau
sur les causes de cette information qui a changé.
Et ça change ce que vous entendez consciemment.
Ces informations montrent le fondement de la perception
sous une nouvelle lumière.
Au lieu d'une perception dépendant largement de signaux extérieurs
entrant dans le cerveau,
elle dépend tout autant, si ce n'est plus,
de prédictions perceptives circulant dans le sens opposé.
Nous ne percevons pas le monde de façon passive,
nous le fabriquons activement.
Notre expérience du monde vient autant, si ce n'est plus,
de l'intérieur que de l'extérieur.
Voici un autre exemple de la perception
en tant que processus actif et constructif.
Nous avons associé la réalité virtuelle en immersion avec le traitement d'image
pour simuler les effets de fortes prédictions perceptives
sur l'expérience.
Dans cette vidéo panoramique, nous avons transformé le monde —
ici, le campus de Sussex —
en terrain de jeu psychédélique.
La vidéo a été éditée avec un algorithme basé sur le Deep Dream de Google
afin de simuler les effets de fortes prédictions perceptives.
Dans ce cas, voir des chiens.
Vous pouvez constater que c'est très étrange.
Lorsque les prédictions sont trop fortes,
comme dans cet exemple,
le résultat ressemble beaucoup aux types d'hallucinations
constatées dans des états seconds
ou peut-être même dans un état psychotique.
Pensez à ça pendant une minute.
Si les hallucinations sont une sorte de perception non contrôlée,
alors la perception ici et maintenant est aussi une sorte d'hallucination,
mais une hallucination contrôlée
où les prédictions du cerveau sont contrôlées
par les informations sensorielles du monde.
En fait, nous hallucinons sans arrêt
et même à cet instant.
Et lorsque nous sommes d'accord sur nos hallucinations,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réalité.
(Rires)
Je vais maintenant vous dire que votre expérience du moi,
l'expérience spécifique d'être vous,
est aussi une hallucination contrôlée et fabriquée par le cerveau.
Cette idée paraît très étrange, non ?
Oui, les illusions visuelles sont trompeuses,
mais comment pourrais-je être dupé à propos de mon identité ?
Pour la plupart d'entre nous, l'expérience d'être une personne
est si familière, si homogène et si permanente
qu'il est dur de ne pas la tenir pour acquise.
Nous ne devrions pas la tenir pour acquise.
Il y a beaucoup de façons différentes de faire l'expérience du moi.
Il y a l'expérience d'avoir un corps
et d'être un corps.
Il y a les expériences de perception du monde
à la première personne.
Il y a celles de vouloir faire des choses
et d'être la cause des choses qui se passent dans le monde.
Et il y a les expériences
d'être une personne distincte et permanente au fil du temps,
créées à partir d'un ensemble de souvenirs et d'interactions sociales.
Des expériences montrent,
les psychiatres et les neurologues le savent,
que ces différentes façons de faire l'expérience du moi
peuvent toutes se disloquer,
ce qui veut dire que l'expérience de base en arrière-plan
du moi homogène est une construction du cerveau assez fragile.
Une autre expérience, qui comme toutes les autres,
exige des explications.
Revenons à notre moi corporel.
Comment le cerveau fabrique l'expérience d'avoir un corps
et d'être un corps.
Les mêmes principes sont applicables.
Le cerveau devine au mieux
ce qui fait et ce qui ne fait pas partie de son corps.
Une superbe expérience en neuroscience illustre ce propos.
Contrairement à la plupart des expériences,
on peut la réaliser à la maison.
Vous n'avez besoin que de ça.
(Rires)
Et de quelques pinceaux.
Dans cette illusion,
la vraie main d'une personne est cachée
et cette main en caoutchouc est placée en face d'elle.
Puis on donne un coup de pinceau aux deux mains en même temps
tandis que la personne fixe la fausse main.
La plupart des gens, à la longue,
finissent par avoir l'étrange sensation
que la main en caoutchouc fait partie de leur corps.
L'idée est que la congruence entre voir le toucher et ressentir le toucher
sur un objet qui ressemble à une main et qui est là où une main devrait être,
est preuve suffisante pour le cerveau pour former l'hypothèse
que la main en caoutchouc fait bien partie du corps.
(Rires)
Vous pouvez mesurer plein de choses astucieuses,
comme la conductivité de la peau et les réactions de surprise
mais ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Il est évident que le gars en bleu a assimilé sa fausse main,
ce qui signifie que même les expériences de notre corps
sont des sortes d'hypothèses —
une sorte d'hallucination contrôlée par le cerveau.
Encore une chose.
Nous faisons l'expérience de nos corps
en tant qu'objets depuis l'extérieur,
mais également depuis l'intérieur.
Nous connaissons tous la sensation d'être un corps depuis l'intérieur.
Les signaux sensoriels venant de l'intérieur du corps
parlent sans arrêt au cerveau de l'état des organes internes,
comment le cœur se porte, la pression artérielle,
beaucoup de choses.
Ce genre de perception, que nous appelons l'intéroception,
est plutôt négligée.
Mais elle est très importante
parce que la perception et la régulation de l'état interne du corps —
c'est ce qui nous maintient en vie.
Voici une autre version de l'illusion de la fausse main.
Ça vient de notre laboratoire.
Ici, les gens voient une version de leur main en réalité virtuelle,
qui clignote rouge
à temps ou à contretemps avec leurs battements de cœur.
Lorsque les clignotements sont en rythme avec leur cœur,
les gens la ressentent plus fortement comme faisant partie de leur corps.
Les expériences d'avoir un corps sont fortement ancrées
dans la perception de nos corps de l'intérieur.
J'aimerais attirer votre attention sur une dernière chose.
Les expériences du corps depuis l'intérieur sont très différentes
des expériences du monde autour de nous.
Autour de moi, le monde semble rempli d'objets —
des tables, des chaises, des fausses mains,
des gens, vous —
même mon propre corps,
je peux le percevoir comme un objet extérieur.
Mais mes expériences intérieures du corps sont complètement différentes.
Je ne perçois pas mes reins ici,
mon foie ici,
ma rate...
Je ne sais pas où est ma rate,
mais elle est quelque part.
Je ne vois pas mes organes comme des objets.
Je n'en fais pas du tout l'expérience sauf quand quelque chose ne va pas.
Je crois que c'est très important.
La perception de l'état interne du corps
ne sert pas à comprendre ce qui est là,
elle sert à contrôler et à réguler —
à garder les variables physiologiques à l'intérieur des strictes limites
compatibles avec notre survie.
Lorsque le cerveau utilise des prédictions pour comprendre,
les objets sont perçus comme les causes des sensations.
Lorsque le cerveau utilise des prédictions pour contrôler et réguler,
nous faisons l'expérience de l'efficacité de ce contrôle.
Nos expériences du moi les plus basiques,
d'être un organisme incarné,
sont ancrées dans les mécanismes biologiques qui nous maintiennent en vie.
Lorsque nous suivons cette idée jusqu'au bout,
nous pouvons constater que toutes nos expériences conscientes,
puisqu'elles dépendent des mêmes mécanismes de perception prédictive,
résultent de notre instinct de survie de base.
Nous faisons l'expérience du monde et de nous-mêmes
avec, à travers et grâce à nos corps.
Laissez-moi tout assembler petit à petit.
Ce que nous voyons dépend
de la meilleure hypothèse du cerveau.
Le monde que nous connaissons vient de l'intérieur,
pas seulement de l'extérieur.
L'illusion de la fausse main montre qu'elle s'applique à nos expériences
de ce qui est et ce qui n'est pas notre corps.
Ces prédictions dépendent essentiellement de signaux sensoriels
venant du plus profond de notre corps.
Enfin,
les expériences d'être une personne incarnée
concernent plus le contrôle et la régulation
que la compréhension.
Nos expériences du monde autour de nous et de nous-même dans ce monde
sont des sortes d'hallucinations contrôlées
formées par des millions d'années d'évolution
pour nous garder en vie dans un monde rempli de danger et d'opportunités.
Nous anticipons notre existence.
Je vais vous laisser avec trois répercussions de cette théorie.
Notre perception du monde et de nous-mêmes peut être faussée
lorsque les mécanismes de prédiction fonctionnent mal.
Cette découverte ouvre de nouvelles opportunités
en psychiatrie et en neurologie
parce que nous pouvons enfin nous attaquer aux mécanismes
au lieu de ne traiter que les symptômes
dans des états de dépression et de schizophrénie.
Deuxièmement :
ce qu'être moi veut dire ne peut pas être réduit ou téléchargé
sur un logiciel implanté dans un robot,
aussi intelligent ou sophistiqué soit-il.
Nous sommes des animaux biologiques, de chair et d'os,
dont les expériences conscientes sont façonnées à tous les niveaux
par les mécanismes biologiques qui nous maintiennent en vie.
Rendre les ordinateurs plus intelligents ne les rendra pas conscients.
Enfin,
notre univers intérieur individuel,
notre façon d'être conscient
n'est que l'une des différentes façons d'être conscient.
La conscience humaine en général n'est qu'une petite zone
d'un vaste espace de consciences possibles.
Notre moi et nos mondes individuels nous sont propres,
mais ils sont tous ancrés dans des mécanismes biologiques
que nous partageons avec beaucoup d'autres créatures vivantes.
Ces changements sont fondamentaux
dans la façon dont nous nous comprenons,
mais ils devraient être célébrés,
parce que comme souvent dans la science, depuis Copernic —
nous ne sommes pas le centre de l'univers —
à Darwin —
nous sommes liés à toutes les autres créatures —
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Avec une plus grande compréhension
vient un plus grand émerveillement
et une plus grande réalisation
que nous faisons partie intégrante de la nature.
Et...
lorsque notre conscience arrive à sa fin,
il n'y a aucune raison d'avoir peur.
Aucune raison du tout.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)